coral sand beaches coconut palms gently
swaying in the ocean breeze
waterfalls
rainbows hawaii is all these things and
many more in fact
hawaii has a deep dark little secret a
secret the u.s government wouldn't like
you to know about
[Music]
[Applause]
have you ever wondered why hawaii is a
part of america after all it's 2 000
miles from the american mainland native
hawaiian people definitely don't look
like americans in any way shape or form
and native hawaiians have their own
culture cuisine and language that is
completely different from western
culture so why is hawaii a part of
america well the answer is it was never
supposed to be hawaii had its own
government its own laws its own economy
and the locals had laid claim to the
islands for more than a thousand years
but then came the americans the
missionaries who wanted to spread the
word of god these missionaries would
soon realize just how profitable sugar
farming could be on hawaii so they
encroached ever so slowly on the native
hawaiians taking their land their
culture their dignity their spirit away
from them inch by inch over the decades
and ever so slowly these americans
gradually beat the hawaiians into
submission all the way until hawaii was
officially recognized as the 50th state
of the us in 1959
see to put it bluntly hawaii was stolen
in every sense of the word their land
stripped from their powership from them
their leaders toppled seized by
americans in the name of chasing the
mighty dollar the establishment of large
sugar plantations was kind of the
colonial force that really
pulled these islands into the chains of
global capital agricultural production
and left behind the legacy of
consolidated land ownership control over
water rights and really the
disenfranchisement and marginalizations
of indigenous people in their homeland
the bottom line
all the way until today where on the
surface hawaii looks like a tropical
paradise a top-tier destination any
tourists will want to visit but if you
look a little deeper this island that
was once the home to an indigenous
population is almost entirely owned by
just 82 land holders we're talking about
95 of hawaii's land being owned by just
82 land holders by 2015. more than half
of that land belongs to a government
that people didn't choose and the rest
it is in the hands of the sugar and
pineapple companies that control the
islands
my name is jake tran i make
documentaries on money power war and
crime in my team subscribe for more if
you want to win a thousand dollars cash
you just have to be following me at
jaketren and you're automatically
entered a few of you have won already
watch out for fake accounts i will never
message you asking for money and this is
how the u.s stole hawaii
[Music]
if you're watching this channel right
now you probably want to be really
successful one day and yeah that's going
to take a lot of hard work but being
successful isn't just about always
grinding in fact most successful people
know that 90 of this game is mental and
a big part of becoming successful is
working through all the mental issues
childhood trauma and relationship issues
that we're all plagued with including
myself and the truth is the best way to
deal with all this is with a therapist
looking back i really wish someone would
have pushed me to do therapy sooner i
used to be super awkward because of all
my insecurities and childhood trauma and
i could have gotten over that way sooner
and easier if i had a little help i
would have been happier sooner i
wouldn't have wasted so many years and i
would have been more successful sooner
but the problem is finding a therapist
in your area is difficult and expensive
but not anymore because that's where
today's video sponsored better
betterhelp comes in betterhelp is
democratizing therapy they're the
largest therapy platform in the world
with over 2 million users it isn't a
crisis line or self-help it's
professional therapy all done securely
online with better help you'll have
access to over 20 000 licensed embedded
therapists all online and getting
started is super easy just give better
help a little information about yourself
and what kind of therapy you're looking
for then based on your needs better help
matches you with a therapist who is the
best fit for you and boom that is it you
can start communicating with your
therapist in as little as 48 hours and
once you're matched you can send them a
message whenever you want you can set up
weekly video or phone calls with your
therapist so you can avoid the
awkwardness of in-person meetings and if
you're not feeling your therapist it's
simple and free to switch to a new one
better help is more affordable than
traditional therapy and financial aid is
available so take control of your future
today by pausing the video and heading
over to
betterhelp.comtran for 10 off your first
month that's betterhelp.com
for 10 off your first month thanks to
better health for sponsoring this video
more than 1 000 years ago a group of
polynesian settlers arrived on the
hawaiian islands these settlers lived
without any real government for 700
years because their cultures never
really needed one and then by 1778
james cook arrived he was the first
european to ever lay foot on the islands
and understandably the native hawaiians
were pretty freaked out by these people
who carried guns and acted like they
owned the place long story short captain
cook and his sailors spent a few weeks
on the islands and ended up giving the
people dozens of western diseases that
wiped out more than half of the
population then on his second visit cook
was mistaken for a polynesian god told
his sailors to steal wood from a sacred
hawaiian burial ground tried to kidnap
one of their kings and got himself
killed because of it not exactly a great
start to hawaiian western relations but
more importantly cook's visits had put
hawaii on the map
even after hearing about the captain's
gruesome death european and american
sailors couldn't help themselves the
allure of hawaii's tropical landscape
natural harbors and the chance to
restock supplies were just too great so
after captain james cook's first visit
to hawaii in 1778 the islands would
never be the same again now was time for
americans to take their chances on the
hawaiian islands but it wasn't just any
americans
they were american missionaries way back
in the 18th century most christians
believed it was their god-given duty to
travel around the world teaching the
heathens and barbarians as they like to
call them about the only true religion
and hawaii was no exception you see
polynesian religion was nothing like
christianity hawaiians believed in many
different gods and that just made the
christian missionaries more determined
to prove them wrong
the only problem was these missionaries
didn't just want to spread their
religion they wanted to force it onto
people better yet they wanted to
completely change hawaiian society to
follow western culture so when boatloads
of american missionaries arrived
carrying guns and telling the hawaiian
people that singing dancing and games
were suddenly illegal they didn't have
much choice but to accept that this was
the new normal
then in the mid-1800s the missionaries
decided to make an even bigger change
this time they thought hawaii would be
easier to control if it had one king
instead of many chiefs and elders one
guy that could tell what to do and the
hawaiian people would just have to nod
and agree so the missionaries installed
a puppet king to rule hawaii and forever
changed the landscape of a power on the
island
whether or not hawaiian people agreed to
this change was irrelevant but hey at
least the kingdom of hawaii as it was
now called still had its independence
and that was a pretty big deal
you see by the late 1800s there were
only 44 completely independent countries
in the world and hawaii was one of them
today there are 197 that meant by 19th
century standards hawaii was pretty
special it wasn't a colony it wasn't a
territory it was a kingdom it didn't
have to answer to anyone except its own
king
but as you can guess
that wouldn't last long
[Music]
[Laughter]
being a missionary and preaching the
word of god on a tiny group of islands
didn't exactly pay well
these american missionaries were dead
broke in hawaii and that was becoming a
problem forget laying up their treasures
in heaven they wanted a little more real
material benefit from all that good news
and gospel they were spreading but
unlike mainland america hawaii didn't
have any gold it didn't have any oil and
didn't have any diamonds but what hawaii
did have was sugar cane
and that's where the missionary struck
sweet white powdery gold sugar by the
1830s the industrial revolution had
spread to america which meant mass
production of white sugar was just
another incredibly lucrative business
and the missionaries wanted in so they
teamed up with the not so religious
american farmers and together made a
plan to turn hawaiian land into the most
profitable sugar plantations ever there
was just one problem
none of the land in hawaii was for sale
in traditional hawaiian culture the idea
of owning land didn't exist plus
american paper money meant nothing to
the native hawaiians and without some
sort of ownership deal the sugar cane
the americans grew could easily be
harvested by pretty much anyone on the
island
not a great business plan luckily that's
where the missionaries friendly little
puppet king came in the guy the
missionaries had put in charge of all of
hawaii he was easily convinced to create
new land reforms that basically cut up
hawaiian land and put it under the
direct control of the king now if any
westerners wanted land they could just
buy it from the king simple the only
problem was none of this made any sense
to native hawaiians who had been living
on shared land for almost 1 thousand
years and even if they wanted to buy
land they couldn't because they had no
money the only people with any of this
real money the king wanted were the
americans and so the american farmers
and missionaries arbitrarily created a
monopoly on land that was never supposed
to be sold in the first place
from there it was nowhere but up for
these humble missionaries and their
patriotic farmer friends they were
planting sugarcane on every piece of
land they could get their hands on they
were harvesting boatloads of sugarcane
ready to export to america there was
just one more issue
import levies the taxes america charged
for goods like sugar coming into the u.s
from another country hawaii after all
wasn't a part of america yet at this
point and that's where the real trouble
for hawaii started
[Applause]
for decades before hawaii became a sugar
exporter america had placed heavy
tariffs or taxes on imported sugar
that's because the u.s had its own sugar
monopoly to deal with basically a small
group of american sugar farm owners had
gotten together and forced the american
government to put massive taxes on any
foreign sugar coming into america that
way the local farmers could set their
sugar prices as high as they liked
without any competition to drive them
back down it was a cookie-cutter
monopoly and a massive problem for
american farmers in hawaii these giant
import tariffs were cutting into their
profits something had to be done so in
1854 under pressure from the american
farmers the puppet king of hawaii made
america an offer it couldn't refuse
reduce tariffs on hawaiian sugar to zero
and we'll give you exclusive rights to
opening commercial and military bases on
our islands to be clear no native
hawaiians wanted any of this they didn't
want to exchange their land so the
american farmers could get rich and they
were worried that exchanging a few
pieces of land for zero tariffs will
lead to all of hawaii falling under
american control someday
but in 1876 the agreement became
official import taxes on hawaiian sugar
went to zero and americans could build
on the islands of hawaii america had
had's foot in the door the number of
hawaiian sugar farms tripled and the
american farmers were making bank but
didn't end there you see the agreement
was supposed to last for eight years
after which it could be renewed but when
the eighth year came around america
decided it didn't really like the terms
of this already great deal exclusive
land rights didn't seem like enough in
exchange for zero tariffs on top of that
mainland american sugar farmers were not
happy they now had all this competition
from hawaii and sugar they had lost
their monopoly and they politely voiced
their concerns to the american
government
so just like a landlord who takes every
chance to increase rent america decided
to strong arm from war this time america
wanted all those exclusive land rights
plus control of pearl harbor by now
pearl harbor had become one of the most
important strategic points in the
pacific ocean and america wanted it for
itself
unsurprisingly the king agreed after all
giving in to the americans wasn't just
an option anymore it was an obligation
drunk on power the american farmers
quickly saw their chance to force the
hawaiian king to hand over even more
control of his country so in 1887 a new
hawaiian constitution was introduced
except this time it was written by
american lawyers and farmers and the
king he was forced to sign it at
gunpoint
what was the biggest change in this new
constitution only landowners could be
allowed to vote or run for office it
didn't matter that most native hawaiians
still didn't own land it also didn't
matter that most landowners were white
americans under the new constitution
native hawaiians lost any say they had
in the destiny of their country the king
had signed away his people's rights and
independence
by now hawaii was practically a de facto
u.s territory only a miracle could save
hawaii now and that miracle came in the
form of queen lilio kalani
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
in 1891 the king of hawaii died and his
sister princess lilio kalani became
queen
unlike her brother queen lilioa kalani
wasn't okay with american farmers
running the country and she spent the
next two years trying to give hawaii its
independence back around the same time
the american sugar farmers ran into
another problem the mckinley act
basically this act removed the tariffs
on all sugar imports to america
now sugar farmers from jamaica to
nicaragua could ship their sugar to
america without any hefty fees the huge
advantage hawaiian sugar farmers once
had was now gone
to keep local american sugar growers
happy the government agreed to pay
farmers an extra two cents per pound for
locally grown sugar but the hawaiian
sugar farmers they were back at square
one in this time no treaty or agreement
could save them the only way they could
maintain their edge and keep their
coffers full was to officially become a
part of america that way they could also
get that juicy two-cent subsidy per
pound of sugar
now imagine the horror these farmers
experienced when in the middle of
planning to become an official american
territory queen lilio kalani comes out
of nowhere and announces her plans for a
new constitution a constitution that
will give native hawaiians back all
their power
if this new constitution is put into
place the americans would be screwed and
for them the solution became obvious it
was time to overthrow the hawaiian
kingdom once and for all
[Music]
[Music]
planned to overthrow hawaii's government
had been in the works for years but when
the queen announced her plan for a new
constitution the americans knew they
would have to act
fast
enter john l stephens lauren thurston
and henry e cooper the american minister
to hawaii an ex-hawaiian government
official and an american lawyer
the three main conspirators they called
themselves the committee for safety a
very inconspicuous name and together
they plan to overthrow the hawaiian
queen and officially put hawaii under
american control
january 14 1893 queen lilio kalani
announces her plans for a new
constitution and the committee for
safety immediately jumps into action
with most of the government consisting
of hawaiian born americans a coup would
be relatively easy the only real problem
would be the queen and her guards would
they put up a fight and if they did
would other native hawaiians join them
luckily an american warship was docked
just a few miles ashore and as the
american minister to hawaii john stevens
had all the authority in the world to
call the soldiers to shore
january 16 1893 the minister does
exactly that and 162 american marines
and sailors land on the island with guns
drawn and artillery in tow
with this show of strength three
conspirators gather a crowd of american
farmers outside the royal palace a day
later with nearly 60 armed american
soldiers by their side and not one
person in the queen's government could
or wanted to help her after decades of
handing power over to america there were
no patriotic hawaiians left in office
defeat is inevitable
and to add insult to injury henry cooper
the american lawyer that helped plan the
coup announced the queen was officially
removed from power without her ever
having one word or say about it
that was it that was the coup no long
drawn-out battle no psychological
warfare on the populace the three
conspirators had literally brought a
couple of soldiers over announced the
queen was no longer in power and
everyone kind of just accepted it
to replace the queen the americans chose
a guy named sanford dull to be the new
leader and that was it
after decades of being told what to do
by americans most native hawaiians
weren't exactly surprised that it ended
like this with even the queen's own
government consisting of more americans
than hawaiians the kingdom's fate was
sealed it was pointless to fight back
hawaii had been ever so slowly beaten
into submission
the only thing the queen could do was
beg the american government for help you
see the committee of safety didn't
exactly have the explicit permission of
the american president to carry out
their coup in fact president grover
cleveland never had any idea what was
going on until it happened the president
was actually a good friend of the queens
he even offered the queen her position
back if she would agree not to prosecute
the people responsible for the coup but
even that was just a formality in
reality the new president of hawaii
stanford dull made it abundantly clear
that that would never happen
the american government had been
checkmated by its own citizens in the
end the american government had no
choice but to recognize the new hawaiian
government the only thing president
cleveland could do to make things even a
little better was refused to accept
hawaii as an official state
so for the next nearly 60 years hawaii
existed only as an independent republic
and a recognized american territory
under the rule of american citizens
and the sugar farmers they got what they
wanted as an american territory hawaiian
sugar farms could enjoy all the benefits
the other american farmers got
[Music]
in 1959 after nearly 60 years of
hawaiian-born americans campaigning to
be part of the united states hawaii was
finally made the official 50th state in
1959.
none of the few native hawaiians left on
the island celebrated in fact in 1993
more than 12 000 hawaiians marched in
protest asking for the return of their
land and their rights
in 2015 95 of hawaii's land was still
owned by just 82 land holders more than
half of that belongs to a state and
government the people didn't choose and
the rest it's still in the hands of the
sugar and pineapple companies and if
that's not enough thousands of native
hawaiians have been waiting for more
than 100 years to gain access to the 200
000 acres of land they were promised by
the us congress in 1920. this land was
supposed to be given to anyone with at
least 50 percent hawaiian ancestry but
since the law passed almost half of that
land has actually gone to non-hawaiians
that's the dark reality you'll never
hear from tour guides in hawaii the
people who have called hawaii home for
more than 1 000 years find themselves
without land or independence waiting for
their share of a hundred thousand acres
of land that's left for them while
american billionaires get to buy entire
hawaiian islands of the same size for
their private use and no one says a
thing
hawaii was america's first taste of
overthrowing a foreign government but it
was far from its last and every time the
american government carried out a coup a
little bit of the world's history would
be altered
countries would end up ruled by
dictators thousands of people would die
and irreparable damage would be done to
the global balance of power but none not
one coup would become quite as important
or have a series of consequences as the
iranian coup of 1953
under pressure from british oil
executives who are about to lose their
share of iran's huge oil fields the cia
created operation ajax using almost
every underhanded tactic in the book
america was directly responsible for the
overthrow of iran's democratically
elected prime minister muhammad masaday
on the surface the operation was a
complete success but no one could have
ever imagined the consequences of such a
coup
that one little coup led by a few
americans on a budget of a couple of
million dollars would be the catalyst
leading to some of the worst terror
attacks in the world just about every
major terror attack you can think of
that would get this video demonetized if
we mentioned it or showed it on screen
can be traced back to this one little
coup in a little-known country called
iran
it's a piece of history that no school
or university will ever teach you which
is why we've turned it into a
full-length documentary showing you
exactly how everything went down and how
it led to the 20-plus year war on terror
we have today it's already age
restricted so there's no chance it could
have gone live on the channel which is
why we've just released the complete
documentary on our private channel which
is only available to members of this
channel and all you have to do to watch
it right now is click that join button
below after you join you'll immediately
get access to this documentary on the
iranian coup along with other equally
controversial ones on the bin laden
papers mk-ultra the cia's mind control
program and many more to come
channel members have been loving the
documentary
people pay tens of thousands of dollars
every year to universities only to leave
not knowing anything about how the world
really works but with this you'll get
all this priceless information for just
five dollars a month and we promise you
it's way more entertaining than
university lectures and there's a refund
policy too unlike most youtube
memberships so if you join and you don't
think it's worth it email us within your
first month of joining and we will
personally refund you for your first
month
after your first month there is no
refund so scroll down and click that
join button below right now
[Music]
have you ever wondered why hawaii is a
part of america i sure have and now we
know the answer if you're new here my
name is jake and this is one of the
biggest channels on youtube for
documentaries on money power war and
crime so if you enjoyed this one we make
multiple videos just like this every
single week for free so click the
subscribe button below you have nothing
to lose and everything to gain if you
use facebook and you want shorter
versions of these videos you can follow
me over there we might be doing
giveaways over there in the future but
yeah that's gonna wrap it up thank you
so much for watching stay dangerous out
there and i will see you guys in the
next one
[Music]
[Music]
you